stéphanie grandmont émilie nicolas et
christian dufour bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoir à une conférence de presse
aujourd'hui pour faire le point sur la
sixième vague on a donc dépassé le cap
des 2000 hospitalisation le réseau
hospitalité est encore sous pression
sous tension et à québec quand les
partis d'opposition demandent au premier
ministre françois legault de reprendre
le leadership on l'a pas vu depuis des
semaines en conférence de presse sur la
copie 19 français legault qui a réagit
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans les couloirs
de l'assemblée nationale on va l'écouter
différentes réactions tout d'abord
on suit ça de très proches
pour l'instant la santé publique nous
recommande pour vous ne pas l'intention
on a eu un gouvernement omniprésent dans
la question de la pandémie avec avec la
santé publique mais aujourd'hui on
assiste à complètement les inverse je
pense qu un juste milieu de jouer de
prudence et une ce serait la bonne chose
qu'à grande crainte c'est le personnel
soignant qui tombe en ce moment au
combat lançant vauvert l'été des
vacances on disait qu'il fallait
prendre des mesures dans toutes les
sphères de la société aujourd'hui ben on
on fait comme si la pandémie était
derrière nous je lancerai la première
question stéphanie dans les
circonstances c'est ce que vous estimez
qui est vraiment le bon en fait assez
dans sa gestion de la pandémie
évaluer quel serait l'impact de chacun
maintenant on se retrouve dans une
situation où une sixième bague est ce
qu'on doit remettre des mesures jeux
réseaux et est pas au point de rupture
on espère qu
est-ce qu est-ce que françois legault
doit s'impliquer davantage je pense que
c'est c'est pas anodin aussi participent
plus aux conférences de presse ils ont
dissocié sa da santé publique parce que
évidemment on est en campagne électorale
avec les élections dans ma victoire et
cette semaine ça manque un peu un coup
d'envoi de la campagne pour les
élections et puis je pense que la caq
vraiment pas envie de rester reclus et
danser dans ces questions là qu'ils sont
pas nécessairement gagnante pour pour la
cac c'est un sujet qui divise beaucoup
on en la population les directives la
santé publique doit-on en remettre
davantage dans les écoles notamment
emilie qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce
que c'était une bonne chance de remettre
la responsabilité de la gestion de la
pandémie au citoyen comme on le fait en
ce moment mais c'est extrêmement
compliqué puis c'est sûr que ça cause
aussi des problèmes dans les provinces
suis encore moins de mesures sanitaires
qu'au québec je pense notamment au
montage où le port du masque est déjà
plus obligatoire depuis un moment c'est
sûr que ça c'est beaucoup de
questionnements il ya des médecins qui
font campagne pour que les gens
continuent à apporter le match tout de
même ceci dit c'est sûr qu'une des
questions que j'ai dans ce contexte pour
le gouvernement que legault c'est la
question c'est la question du délestage
en fait c'est la question des gens sur
les listes d'attentes quand on nous
rassure en nous disant que les hôpitaux
sont pas atteints de capacité est ce que
ça veut dire que quand même lorsque les
lits d'hôpitaux sont de plus en plus
occupés par des passants que vides ça
ralentit le rattrapage qu'on a à faire
ce sont des gens qui sont en attente des
fois depuis plus d'un an pour des
chirurgies qu'on a jugé non urgentes
c'était le débat qu'on avait au mois de
décembre au 2 janvier de lordat
cinquième bague puis on dirait que ce
qu'on sait quels sont les complètement
évacuée de la façon dont on calcule les
lits d'hôpitaux dont on a besoin le
seuil le seuil de où le taux
d'hospitalisation qui est acceptable
pour la société québécoise en ce moment
christian les parties ont tellement
demandé d'avoir des points de presse
indépendante de ceux du gouvernement
est-ce qu'on est quand même allé un peu
trop loin à l'autre extrême en laissant
presque tout le terrain
adopté en bois l'eau finalement l'un des
points de presse avec le ministre dubé
puis avec le prévenu se félicite même
qu'on n'a pas vu ça c'est sûr que le
gouvernement monsieur legault en
particulier on sent qu'ils ne veulent
pas dramatiser
une situation qui est sérieuse mais je
crois que moi je regrette qu on utilise
en fait l'expression sixième bague parce
que c'est inutilement anxyogène ça
rappelle les premières vagues qui était
vraiment autre chose beaucoup plus
dramatiquement rappelons qu'au québec
comporte encore le basque en est un des
seuls endroits où on porte encore le
masque
donc ce n'est pas une mesure mineur ce
qui me semble manquer en fait bon c'est
de rappeler aux gens aux populations
d'ailleurs qui sont pas en danger
l'importance de la troisième dose du
vaccin ça me semble être vraiment là
qu'une chose que le messager pas assez
envoyé avait fait que la troisième dose
le qui était recommandée avant l'oeuvre
amant elle est très très fortement
recommandé pour leur chance qui pose
question à moins d'une catastrophe ou
compris voient pas de revenir avec des
mesures sanitaires des contraintes le
danger évidemment c'est que ces mesures
là on fait mal la population je trouve
qu'au québec on y est allé un peu fort
je lui dis je le redis donc finalement
le danger c'est que là on relâche en
relâchant large manquerait moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est que le gouvernement bon
c'est pas une et 100 m messieurs legault
mais peut-être une campagne de publicité
de rappeler que l'os et les gens qui
sont responsables la troisième dose
allez-y le masque on va voir il faut pas
trop la troisième dose qui est quand
même beaucoup moins populaire que les
deux premières on l'a vu l'un dans les
dernières semaines on est à l'aube du
long week-end de pâques y en a qui ont
des rassemblements familiaux qui sont
prévues taux de tam rapide sur cette
question là stéphanie est ce qu elle
appelle à la prudence ça suffit où il ya
des directives plus claires qui seraient
nécessaires à votre avis
c'est sûr qu'un appel à la prudence est
toujours utile bien entendu mais moi je
chérirai sur ce que c'est que christian
disait je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ne se sont pas fait vacciner
parce que le son de cloche était pas
très clair il ya des spécialistes qui
disait enfants il ya pas très longtemps
que si on l'avait eu et on est des
minions avoir mis la corde depuis noël
il y avait pas d'empressement y avoir je
fais les mains d'andré moment c'est sain
exactement le même que ça pourrait être
utile d'attendre sorte que lui
aujourd'hui on a le comité consultatif
canadien là qui nous dînons allez-y
c'est le temps c'est utile est patent
qu'il vaudrait
il voudrait bien là
parce que évidemment c'est un outil qui
est très efficace emilie est ce qu'elle
est la directive a donné plus clairement
pour le long week-end mais c'est sûr que
éviter les grands rassemblements porter
le masque je pense que c'est des choses
qui vont qui vont sous le sens en ce
moment il ya moins de d'abondance de
grands rassemblements drain le temps de
pâques et que durant les fêtes de fin
d'année ceci dit je sais pas si encore
des gens au québec qui ne connaissent
personne qui l a crevé dans ce moment où
tu viens là où qui vient là bang est
encore en isolement mais mais le fait
est que c'est il ya tellement de gens en
ce moment qu'ils ont lakovic qui est
nécessairement salle a un impact sur les
rapports de moi qui sont possibles pas
durant durant le long week-end et
christian qu'est ce que vous en pensez
l'inspiron que le bouton va revenir
bientôt au rap rock aussi eu des
problèmes de grip c'est pas juste
lakovic 19 puis aussi il faut éviter une
espèce d' approche anxiogène ça fait
deux ans qu'on était dans une approche
très anxiogène je pense qu'il faut
dépasser ça il ya le troisième lien
entre québec et lévis dont je vais vous
parler ce soir parce qu'elle conférence
de presse demain du gouvernement de
françois legault projet très très cher
au gouvernement de la carte quand depuis
les dernières élections il va être plus
modeste finalement ce projet là avec
deux tunnels plutôt qu'un moins de voix
moins cher il serait sous les 7
milliards projet qui a été présenté au
maire de québec et de lévis on va
d'abord et écoutez la réaction
mais ce que j'ai vu c'est un magnifique
projet et c'est un projet d'avenir c'est
un projet d'avenir pour le transport en
commun on voit éliminer une fois pour
toutes le fameux fer à cheval entre les
deux rives nous on demeure toujours avec
la bleue la même question qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour l'étalement urbain comme
on en fait un projet qui est
environnementale qui est intéressant
comme on en fait un projet qu'il
n'ajoutera pas la circulation automobile
à québec comment on fait pour avoir une
évaluation avec des faits qui vont nous
démontrer qu'on est capable de rendre
intéressant les mêmes questions
demeurent le gouvernement connaît nos
questions connaît nos conditions et il
va travailler avec eux
vous attendez à quel accueil projets
plus modestes qui va voir justement
quelle réaction stéphanie on est à
quelques mois des prochaines élections
ça va dépendre de quai à quel point on a
des détails dans ce convoi nous
présenter parce que bon c'est bien le
dire
a priori c'est une bonne chose parce que
sur le plan technique d'avoir un seul
tunnel qui est extrêmement large ça
aurait pris un tuner n'y est plus gros
que ceux qu'on n'a jamais utilisé
partout à travers le monde et donc ça ça
ça paraissait extrêmement périlleux si
on peut si on peut arriver avec une
solution qui est sur le plan technique
un petit peu plus réaliste évidemment
tout le monde doit s'en réjouir par
contre ça règle pas tout
évidemment le film s'est cru à cet
endroit là donc il y aura une pente est
forte pour sortir du tunnel safran sort
que pour les poids lourds la vitesse
sera réduite que pour le la circulation
des marchandises dangereuses ça serait
pas possible donc trouvée pour régler
puis au delà des aspects techniques
qu'on on essaie de le résoudre - je
pense la question la plus importante
mais ça c est ce qu on a besoin d'un
troisième ligne et donc si la réponse et
il n'y a pas de repos d'augmentation de
la population active sur la rive sud au
cours des 20 prochaines années où est la
justification je comprends le cas
évidemment c'est c'est pour réduire le
fesf à lecce terrain mais c'est quand
même beaucoup d'argent on parlait de
jusqu'à 10 milliards pour la première
version
est-ce que ce que ça soit moins bon
peut-être mais quand même c'est
énormément d'argent y aurait peut être
mieux à faire pour résoudre les
problèmes de congestion dans la région
voyez encore des gens qu'on vend un cran
sur le bien fondé de ce projet là ml on
entendait le maire de québec ce matin
qu'ils disaient qu'ils craignaient
l'étalement urbain par le transport
collectif d'environnement des conditions
essentielles à rencontrer à votre avis
absolument non seulement ces conditions
le sont essentiels à rencontrer mais
c'est en les mettant sur la table on
voit bien qu'elles sont est incompatible
avec l'idée même d'un 3ème bien selon
moi je ne vois pas comment on peut faire
un trois amis sans favoriser de facto
l'état l'étalement urbain je ne connais
pas de petit village de communauté à
québec qui ont été épargnées par les
pales étalement urbain sûrement que
l'autoroute s'est élargie ou qu'elle
s'est rendue jusqu'à 1 ceci dit je
trouve ça aussi vraiment ça me fait
sourire en fait qu'on en parle désormais
comme comme un projet modeste en fait on
est passé d'une évaluation de 8
milliards à 10 milliards on est passé à
7 milliards puis c'est la magie de la
psychologie en fait d'avoir d'avoir
proposé d'abord un projet tellement
tellement chers qui ont des 107
milliards on a l'impression que c'est un
projet qui est abordable alors que 7
milliards de dollars ça reste un projet
quand même pharaonique avec ses cigares
donnera finalement est ce qui avait été
annoncé d'entrée de jeu exactement ils
sont avait proposé d'emblée un projet 7
milliards de dollars personne ne répond
plus qualifiés sur des projets modestes
avec 7 milliards de dollars ce qu'on
peut faire en éducation ce qu'on peut
faire dans le réseau des cpe ce qu'on
peut faire en santé nouveau la santé des
personnes en ag et est absolument
gigantesque aussi donc je pense que
c'est intéressant que la caq essaie de
présenter un projet 7 milliards de la
com com comme un projet modeste c'est
fascinant nouveau la communication
politique qui mérite on entend des cris
ce temps la réaction du maire de lévis
gilles lehouillier qui semblait beaucoup
plus heureux que celui de québec un
bruno marchand ouais je trouve que ces
projets là le tramway et le troisième le
sont beaucoup trop politisé et
idéologique moi j'ai vécu 25 ans à
québec levé que j'adore en fait et je
trouve que la région de québec devrait
avoir les deux et le tramway et le 3e
minute je pense que les deux sont
difficiles et compatibles j'espère que
le maire
de québec en fait bruno marchand que
gagner son tramway on va voir un peu de
vision et d'emploi il va être positif
ils vont collaborer avec le gouvernement
du québec pourquoi le troisième les
surréalistes aussi moi je prends
vraiment que les deux se sont donné les
moyens de se payer ça mais j'ai un point
personnel là dedans moi ce qui me
dérange beaucoup par rapport à québec
québec c'est une ville où la qualité de
vie est exceptionnelle et c'est une
ville magnifique roman de sites très
classe ceux qui ont voyagé dans le monde
savent qu'on ne parle toujours de québec
une des plus belles villes du monde qui
on dit souvent chaline fois je m'en
souviens encore et moi j'ai peur qu'on
construise des horreurs c'est ça ma
préoccupation pour moi je suis un du
complexe g je me souviens en fait à
l'époque de l'hôtel le concorde de
l'auberge des gouverneurs de ce qu'on a
fait avec le boulevard rené-lévesque
personnes parlent de ça moi je trouve
qu'il faut les deux mais ces
infrastructures locke peuvent défiguré
une des plus belles villes du monde il
serait peut-être le toc des gens qui
s'intéressent à l'esthétisme à
l'élégance à la classe parce que c'est
un capital la beauté de québec d'autres
profitent tous on aura les détails donc
demain en conférence de presse en
concernant ce projet de québec en
terminant rapidement un mot sur
l'ukraine le président américain joe
biden qui a qualifié les ags la russie
de génocide et menait macro lui refuse
d'utiliser ce terme et l'adx et qui veut
pas d'escaladé mot la question était
posée juste être d'eau qui finalement
dit qu'on peut de plus en plus parler de
génocide on est un peu entre deux ans
stéphanie là dessus oui ben c'est ça
c'est je pense que la réponse à savoir
moelle avoir un car il ya des enquêtes
en qui vont faire leur travail sont
allés sur le terrain qui vont récolter
l'épreuve donc c'est là la cour pénale
internationale qui peut nous vraiment
tracer la frontière qu'est ce qui est un
crime de guerre qu'est ce qui est un
génocide c'est sûr que quand on parle de
génocide ont
ainsi que poutine ne veut pas même
reconnaître une identité les élus
craignent et s'éteint c'est quand même
un signe que des risques qu'on
s'approche de ça mais bon pour l'instant
c'est comment tracer la ligne ça prend
des enquêteurs et c'est lourd de sens
pour le droit international en quelques
secondes emilie est ce que c'est la
prudence ou un manque de leadership la
part de justin trudeau mais en fait ce
qui se passe ce que depuis en 2005
l'adoption de la politique de la
responsabilité de protéger utilisez des
mots comme génocide crimes de guerre ça
implique aussi donc la responsabilité
des états de faire quelque chose donc je
pense que dans l'hésitation certains
états à utiliser le mot faut comprendre
que ces bonnes femmes en une une
hésitation devant devant les réalités
qui sont devant nous plutôt que de ce
que ça implique d'aller en faire plus en
ukraine puis d'aussi quand on n'utilise
pas le mot génocide qu'est ce que ça
implique dans notre absence de volonté
d'aller aussi intervenant dans certains
pays où il ya de tout autant des crimes
de guerre des crimes contre l'humanité
ou 6 ans qui ont qui sont là donc c'est
une c'est une déception qui
malheureusement est devenu complètement
politique et à suivre on n'aura pas le
temps christian de terminer là dessus
mais stéphanie milliers christian jour
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là ce soir ça
bientôt vous remercie pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit